ambiances festives sur de la musique
rock pour rendre hommage aux victimes du
terrorisme
les fatals picards ont participé à
l'événement play for humanity ce
vendredi 11 novembre à la salle du
scarabée de la verrière un concert
particulier pour les membres du groupe
touchée par les attentats du 13 novembre
yves notre bassiste et nono qui s'occupe
du plateau était dans la salle avec
nathalie aussi qui viennent de lumière
mais qui est malheureusement décédé au
bataclan et donc du coup c'est pour ça
que genre ce truc à une sorte de
résonance un petit peu funeste pour nous
dimanche soir on va jouer avec une
pensée particulière poil mais mais mais
voilà c'est tous les jours qu'on y passe
pour nous chaque concert c'est un moyen
de rappeler certaines valeurs qu'on
défend qui correspondent pas tout à fait
à celle que défend des les personnes qui
se sont permis d'assister au bataclan
aux côtés des fatals picards le groupe
n'a elle bande les membres incarnent des
personnages de jeux de rôle et mélangent
musique médiévale et celtique avec un
style rock
le nail vente c'est un peu un groupe de
musique traditionnelle qui se comporte
comme un groupe de métal sur fun c'est
un peu je pense que c'est un peu le
concept est très chaotique c'est
n'importe quoi
la distorsion en moins par colonna il
avait selon les faux banjo et la flûte
cor fois les connaît
non
mais bon
on pense que la culture le sens de la
fête le sens du partage
c'est quand même beaucoup plus important
la musique rue d'la marde sous toutes
ses formes
c'est ce qui permet de progresser dans
nos civilisations
les bénéfices seront reversés au profit
de l'association française des victimes
du terrorisme